[Musique]
au sommaire de par soixante dix huit
l'invité charles-henri bacheliers avec
sa société versicolor il est à la tête
de golf magazine du mondial du golf et
des trophées du golfe gros plan sur le
domaine du haras de jardy tennis et golf
sans oublier les conseils techniques
dépôt je vous présente charles ribe à se
dire bonjour
ce commercial c'est pas beau mais ça le
fait ça le fait alors vous êtes de la
société versicolor qui possède golf
magazine le mondial du golf
les trophées du golfe donc on va parler
golf avec vous un un petit peu quand
même nom entre de swing allez on y va
alors d'abord un mot versicolor la
société c'est un mot qui vient quoi ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils
changent de couleur qui sert en fonction
des opportunités
car à l'origine je suis banquier
d'affaires est spécialisé dans les
reprises d'entreprises en transition et
je la vocation à investir dans tous
secteurs et donc versicolor on change de
couleur on va à gauche à droite voilà
vous disiez je reprends des entreprises
et berghuis magazines notamment entre
autres qui a été une opportunité en fait
j'ai su que golf magazine était en vente
au moment où je développais le mondial
du golf
et ça m'a permis de valider un modèle
que je connais bien c'est à dire
l'association de presse spécialisée et
d'événements de passion
et donc j'ai tenté j'ai ma chance et
j'ai gagné
voilà donc et c'est ça fait maintenant
un peu plus d'un an et c'est un plaisir
parce que c'est magnifique revue avec
des équipes génial et surtout on fait
vivre la passion et on permet aux
golfeurs de de vivre mieux le golf est
donc ça c'est assez plaisant
oui c'est un magazine qui est très bien
fait là où il ya une partie évidemment
une partie technique importante
en fait tous les golfeurs de vente sa
baisse et c'est une torture en fait 1
donc bon on peut prendre des semaines
des mois a gagné un coup donc on essaye
de répondre humblement en s'appuyant sur
de vrais spécialistes et eelv et très
bons des très bons
aux problématiques récurrentes courante
que rencontrent les joueurs de tous
niveaux
puisqu'il ya des trucs sur les sorties
de bunker scoop vous avez regardé je lis
tout mais j'ai du mal à mettre en
application je suis pas bonne élève
on va regarder mon cher l'on respire
comptes français c'est pas dans le
bunker c'est contre un arbre c'est
pratiquement injouable hec le jeu donc
on va
on va défendre contre le parcours voilà
on va essayer de la remettre sur la
cuisine des courageux s'étaient pas
glorieux mais en même temps déjà ne pas
la déplacer pour la jouer c'était pas
mal donc maintenant elle est un peu plus
jouable on va essayer de la mettre au
drapeau là c'est pas facile parce que le
sol est dur je le dis
alors on va reparler un peu de golf
magazine jusqu'à la balle ça ça va
soucis aux gens qui ne connaissent pas
le goal qu'ils veulent de découvrir
alors c'est toute la difficulté quand on
fait un magazine grand public comme
celui là parce que on a à peu près 200
mille lecteurs pas par mois soit 96
milles selon logitech qui tu sais quand
même ce qui est très très sérieux c'est
d'essayer de concilier du débutant
voilà qui est qui qui rentrant de se
demander si va jouer s'équiper ou
qu'elle joue et une deux fois avec avec
des amis et aussi permettre de faire
progresser des gens qui sont d'un index
de 40 30 20 10 et moi voilà sachant que
ce qu'on sait c'est que plus l'index est
faible - et son lecteur de golf magazine
qui sont moins cons besoin de conseils
techniques
oui donc il faut arriver à concéder tous
les publics vous même le le golfe
vous l'avez découvert jeunes alors oui
quand j'avais 15 ans enfin par rapport
aux petits champions c'est tardivement
mais assez assez avec avec des amis
voilà et je jouais à mortefontaine
magnifique golf magnifique golf jeu que
j'aime beaucoup mais il n'aime pas
beaucoup elle n'a pas même pas du tout
surtout la bruyère
alors vous laisse vous voilà se jouer
vous allez jouer quoi
[Musique]
bravo à vue où elle était la première
c'est pas mal mise en jambes compliqué
ouais enfin dont on ne parlera avec
initiateurs de parcours mais il est pas
si simple que ça il pas il peut paraître
simple il est pas si facile
court mais technique voilà on va
continuer à parler de ses activités dans
le golfe donc il ya le mondial du golf
quel you ou alors il a lu à
mantes-la-jolie sur une île de la scène
donc à peu près une demi heure de paris
de paris ouest sous un barnum géant avec
énormément de practice qui sont
installés dessus
oui pour ceux qui connaissaient le le
salon du golf alors vous pouvez taper
des balles mais qui à l'aide d'un filet
trop matelassé des vrais practice a
premièrement si on pratique le golf
c'est aussi parce qu'on aime se
retrouver en dehors de paris dans un
lieu vers donc quelque chose qui est une
respiration et d'aération et qui nous
permettent d'être dans un milieu
bucolique comme ici au haras de jardy
magnifique voilà c'est 1 5 10 minutes de
paris et également de l'autre chose qui
est très frustrant c'est taper dans les
filets et ne pas voir ça va le volet
quoi alors on a la sensation de sortie
de 2,2 de deux clubs le bruit le tout
voiture c'est pas vraiment un pro un pro
derrière qui oui c'était très bien mais
en fait la balle qui s'arrêtera à 3
mètres on sait pas là la balle vole
vraiment c'est en plus c'est un moyen de
tester du matériel puisqu'il ya tous les
exposants qui sont là c'est c'est le but
voilà c'est le sport le le golfe selon
les pratiquant le sport le plus
technique au monde voilà il n'ya pas un
sport plus compliqué plus porté sur la
technique est donc le matériel est
quelque chose qui rend fou et on a envie
toujours d'être équipé au mieux pour
pouvoir gagner ces fameux quelques coups
qui font la différence
on peut quand même donner les dates du
prochain mondial du 19 au 21 mars donc
jeudi vendredi samedi et avec cette
volonté de proposer aux golfeurs le
meilleur parce qu'il le mérite alors on
voulait stopper puis on reparle des
trophées du golfe
[Musique]
les trophées du golfe écoutez les
trophées du golf c'était la volonté déjà
une rencontre avec antoine robinson son
créateur et la volonté de proposer à la
home monde du golf à l'industrie un
produit complet logique où on va de la
presse spécialisée à l'événement passion
pour tous tout perdre toute personne
tout public ouvert qu'est le mondial du
golf et à la soirée professionnelle en
gros 2 and markets
on retrouve les gens qui font le golf de
la partie industrielle et sportive ce
qu'ils font club qui gère les parcours
qui font tout ce que nous utilisons
quotidiennement pour pouvoir jouer au
golf et donc maintenant les trophées du
golfe vont changer de date
ils auront lieu le 18 mars comme par
hasard la veille de l'ouverture du
mondial
ah oui donc tout ça n'était lié toujours
en direct sur chez nos confrères de golf
plus voilà est toujours pas au pavillon
gabriel voilà avec quelques nouveautés
qu'on pourra vous présenter très bientôt
donc ça va être une nouveauté dans les
trophées du golfe
ça fait beaucoup de beaucoup de s'il
peut dire d'investissement et financier
et professionnel dans le golfe
il ya une chose qu'on peut dont on peut
parler si vous êtes d'accord c'est que
vous jouer au golf et vous jouez bien et
pourtant vous avez eu un
une blessure qui est qui rend la
pratique du vol difficile voilà alors
pour les gens qui disent que c'est
sportivement c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué techniquement
j'en souffre quasiment à chaque fois que
je joue comme tout le monde mais c'est
ça aussi qu'on va chercher un set se
battre contre un parcours oui j'ai eu un
peu le mot thorax il ya 18 mois donc qu
un décollement de la plèvre et qui
nécessite pour être réduits une
opération assez lourde
donc maintenant j'ai six côtes de prix
dans des tissus cicatriciels ce qui
n'est pas génial pour pouvoir swinguer
c'est un droit de gauche et en dépit de
ça on arrive quand même à pratiquer en
travaillant les assouplissements et donc
ça casse le coup à plusieurs idées en
disant que quand on est cassé ou qu'on a
subi des traumatismes physiques le golfe
on peut pas quand on a mal au dos mal au
genou tout ça on peut on peut et même
quand ça a été des choses relativement
sérieux parce que c'est quelque chose de
compliqué qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter
pour pour vos activités pour golf
magazine pour borloo alors le mondial du
golf
on l'a dit ça sera donc au mois de mars
vous souhaitez combien de visiteurs il
ya un objectif
écoutez cette année on vise entre quinze
et vingt mille visiteurs après il ya
plein de choses qui influent sur le
visiteur a le temps ci il fait meilleur
accueil fait qu'à venir visiter
enfin voila mais en tout cas après des
années compliquées dans l'événementiel
gold grand public et les dernières
années du salon du golf qui avait pas
totalement satisfait des visiteurs et
professionnels ont narré enclencher un
cercle vertueux l'année dernière enfin
au printemps dernier donc en avril 2019
et on va vraiment proposer quelque chose
de génial pour les golfeurs on a va
investir beaucoup et je suis sûr que
tous ceux qui feront l'effort de venir à
la rencontre de ceux qui font le golf le
golf en france et ils se régaleront et
passer un bon moment entre amis
merci beaucoup s'est relevé bacheliers
et puis bonne partie à la merci qu'on
vous laisse
[Musique]
bonjour à tous on a donc confié la tâche
cette semaine danese et le swing de
monsieur charles henri bacheliers on
voit beaucoup de choses qui sont
relativement bonnes dans ce qui fait
malheureusement au niveau des
fondamentaux
il est là des petites choses à à réviser
de manière à gagner en efficacité
il y à une flexion très importante du
bas du corps donc ce que je pourrais
dans un premier temps lui suggérer déjà
c'est de faire assez attention à la
manière dont il vient se positionner
devant la balle notamment au niveau du
placement du bassin et de la colonne
vertébrale
ce qu'on recherche plutôt dans une
posture au golf c'est effectivement le
fait déjà de bien placer le bassin dans
le prolongement de la colonne donc on va
chercher dans un premier temps à créer
de l'angle ici au niveau des hanches
voilà en essayant de maintenir le bas du
dos bien à plat ce qui a tendance à
étirer un petit peu ici les musiques
qu'on appelle les ischio-jambiers à
l'arrière des cuisses et une fois qu'on
a trouvé cette sensation on va dans une
recherche de pression verticale vers le
sol un peu comme si on cherchait à venir
enfoncer les genoux dans les chevilles
et en aucun cas on ne cherche par contre
à s'asseoir voilà donc simplement ce
petit exercice très simple pour le
placement ou je fais attention et je
veille à garder le bas du dos à plat et
une fois que je suis dans cette position
je recherche une pression verticale vers
le sol
voilà est également un grip qui me
semble un petit peu faible voire dans la
paume
c'est à dire qu'il a une position qui
est dit faible c'est-à-dire une main
gauche qui est tourné vers la cible avec
un club qui est positionné du coup non
pas dans les doigts mais dans la paume
de la main
et ceci va poser quelques difficultés
alors j'accentue un petit peu la
position pour mieux comprendre ce que
cela va occasionner une fois qu'il va
démarrer il peut très bien faire la
première partie qu'on appelle le take
away de manière excellente mais comme le
poignet placé dans cette position il a
uniquement la possibilité de casser le
poignet dans ce sens là ce qui par
contre pose un problème de contrôle de
la fin
deux clubs qui est je vous le rappelle
la cause principale de la direction
initiale de la balle gendron on va la
faire démarrer
donc du coup de manière à ce qu'ils
évitent de faire ceci qui a tendance à
changer l'orientation de sa phase de
club et qui fait qu'elle est positionné
de manière dite fermée
c'est à dire qu'elle évolue vers la
gauche de la cible quand il monte je
proposerai simplement déjà d'essayer
dans un premier temps de se relaxer
beaucoup plus de manière à retrouver une
position plus naturelle du bras gauche
déjà par rapport au club avec un club
qui ai pris un peu plus dans les doigts
donc partant de la phalange du milieu de
l'index est vraiment jusqu'à la base du
petit doigt
voilà donc le club est pris dans les
doigts et ensuite on vient refermer la
main comme ceux ci sur le club ce qui va
lui donner la possibilité de pouvoir
également armé dans ce sens vers le haut
et vers le bas ce qu'on privilégie
plutôt on va dire au golf voilà et ce
qui lui permettra du coup d'éviter
simplement de modifier l'orientation de
sa phase de club pendant qu'il va
prendre son élan c'est à dire faire son
backswing simplement voilà et donc moi
je vous demanderai simplement de faire
attention à cette petite chose là s'il
en a un doute sur la neutralité de ce
modèle domagoj demanderai simplement
d'allonger le bras de l'homme est en
extension complète de manière à vérifier
que la phase deux clubs est toujours
bien square voilà par rapport à la
direction laquelle il a souhaité faire
partir laval voilà
[Musique]
alors je suis avec régis yater qui est
le directeur du golf du tennis et
restaurants des haras de jardy alors
haras de jardy parce que soit l'origine
c'est des arts oui à l'origine voilà des
rats et ensuite ils ont construit donc
des terrains de tennis et un golf et un
restaurant dernièrement sur l'ensemble
du domaine
c'est depuis quand le restaurant il a
ouvert le nouveau restaurant ouvert en
janvier 2010 cette nuit et nous
l'exploitons avec la terrasse ouverte
toute l'année même magnifique magnifique
endroit là c'est vrai que c'est un
endroit tout près de paris tout près de
versailles au pôle et will su si on veut
le situer géographiquement c'est ça oui
tout à fait oui on est à moins de dix
minutes de la porte de saint cloud et à
moins de 10 minutes de saint quentin en
yvelines
alors puisque on commençait par le
parler de tennis il ya combien de
pratiquer un tennis voilà alors nous
avons à peu près 800 participants
pratiquants qui viennent en pratique
libre et abonnés et nous avons autant de
jeunes licenciés en école de tennis
d'accord parce qu'il ya deux formules on
peut venir prendre un coup on loue un
court pour jouer une heure par exemple
mais on peut être on peut être aussi
abonnés voilà tout à fait on peut venir
pratiquer sur les différentes surfaces
quick synthétique terre-battue ya tous
été pratiquée à leur réserver son
terrain tennisman et est également
l'abonnement en fonction de la météo car
nous avons quatre terrains couverts et
et 16 terrains extérieurs à leurs
parents aussi du golfe
je crois qu'il ya combien 1500 licenciés
dont sur la partie tout à fait sur la
partie golf 1500 licenciés au total
entre le tennis et le golf nous sommes à
peu près 3000 licenciés demi qui
viennent pratiquer et 7 jours sur 7
l'activité golf ou tennis alors il ya un
practice naturellement et puis il ya
aussi un parcours de neuf trous
voilà il ya un practice de 80 postes
éclairé éclairé lui de 7 heures du matin
d'un très tôt le matin jusqu'à très tard
le soir 23 heures
trois heures jusqu'à 23 heures vous
pouvez venir taper des incroyables amis
sur l'ensemble du practice et on a
également en effet un parcours 9 trous
qui se fait à peu près en 1h15 1h30
homologuées jusqu'au jusqu'à 0 donc les
meilleurs joueurs également peuvent
venir jouer ici et qui nous sert
également de zone d'entraînement une
compétition pour tous niveaux
alors disait qu'un seul licencié il ya
aussi beaucoup de jeunes qui apprennent
le golf isi voilà nous avons une école
de golf
voilà nous avons une école de golf avec
golf de 250 jeunes qui vont pratiquer
toute l'année entre une heure à deux
heures d'activités avec accès au
parcours en montée et ça jusqu'au mois
de juin puisqu on le disait qui
appartient enfin autre scène
donc il ya peut-être une faveur qui fait
aux gens qui habitent dans les
hauts-de-seine non en fait il ya à peu
près plus de 60% de résidents des autres
scènes qui viennent pratiquer ici avec
beaucoup de clients de la commune de
vaucresson
nous sommes sur la commune de vaucresson
de marnes-la-coquette n'est qu'un avant
des habitants de boulogne billancourt
donc c'est 60 % de pratiquants ici qui
sont ce des hauts-de-seine qui sont des
hauts-de-seine et donc ils bénéficient
d'une remise sur leurs tarifs de 8 % sur
leurs activités en s'inscrivant ici
alors on parle beaucoup il ya parfois
des polémiques des ja en disant d'alcool
fsa utilise beaucoup 12
vous avez une politique très écologique
donc tout à fait voilà nous avons été
retenu dans cette démarche et c'est une
vraie volonté du département des
hauts-de-seine d'avoir en gestionnaires
d une activité sans produits vitaux donc
on est complètement 100% en organique
le golf et l'ensemble même du site est
labellisé golf éco durable donc nous
sommes cinq golfs en france à avoir
cette référence est le seul golf en
france
avoir un deuxième label qui le label eve
qui est donc sur les environnements
protéger végétalisée du de l'ensemble du
domaine
c'est à dire conforme également notre
personnel à une pratique plus régulière
mécanique avec beaucoup d'à plus
d'attention et on arrive à un très bon
résultat aujourd'hui grâce à une équipe
de terrain qui est très attentive à
cette démarche
allah vous même voilà vous êtes le
directeur du golf gti 10 et les
restaurants mais vous êtes aussi un
grand sportif vous avez été champion du
monde de des rivages quoi oui tout à
fait voilà avant de reprendre la
direction de l'équipement sportif j'ai
fait mes armes dans le sport sur en
voile
en clair de sport et en dériveur ça vous
manque pas trop la fox a manqué j'essaie
de trouver des occasions pour pouvoir
les invités d'honneur il va pas arrêter
comme ça quand honda et estivaux là bas
je souhaite y retourner et naviguer un
peu plus loin régis ce palier de gens
qui osent 0 dorothée cap qui veut
peuvent aussi s'entraîner ici mais il ya
aussi on est tous débutants au golf on
peut venir tout à fait en fait tout le
mois de septembre nous avons des portes
ouvertes qui permet justement qui permet
de faire découvrir le golf pour tous les
âges
on accueille des familles qui viennent
ici suite à des ventes et opérations que
nous avons menées sur le 78 92 et donc
après l'objectif c'est qu'ils viennent
pratiquer autant qu'ils veulent on a
différentes formules à proposer mais
surtout des initiations gratuites sur
tout le mois de septembre sur ici sur
différents golf golf à tout âge hélas
ces deux sélections dire que vous disiez
ça parce que je crois que parmi les gens
qui viennent pratiquement tous les jours
ici est une dame qui a plus de 80 ans qu
elle s'appelle ça s'appelle madeleine
sais pas ce que je vais essayer ces
deux-là trouvé sur le sur le parcours
parce que j'aimerais bien savoir comment
on fait quand tendent à 84 ans je crois
pour jouer tous les jours
merci infiniment à 18 heures mais ce
virus au revoir
[Musique]
à
je suis avec madeleine bonjour madeleine
bonjour voilà quelle surprise la télé
venir est ce qu'on peut dire votre âge
ou pas bien sûr bon ben je vais avoir 84
ans pas vrai et vous venez
pratiquement tous les jours jouer au
golf au haras de jardy
oui parfait sous je suis contente parce
que j'ai trouvé vraiment quelque chose
qui m'occupe bien et en plus c'est très
convivial
on a vraiment des personnes sympas comme
tout puis un directeur qu'il fait plein
de choses qui nous occupe bien donc ça
rend heureux de venir ici
créé et puis ça fait vivre longtemps vu
comme ça j'espère et je souhaite à tout
le monde
mettez vous au golf c'est chouette merci
beaucoup bagdad et bonne partie
la paix
alors je suis avec pierre nieto qui est
le directeur des activités physiques et
sportives de l'université de 2,50 à la
pierre on voit pas mal de gens qui sont
derrière vous qui sont celles où alors
c'est jacent des personnels de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines avec lesquels le haras de
jardy le golf tennis de jardy a passé
des accords et donc ils bénéficient de
cours tout une fois par semaine tous les
vendredis entre 12h30 et 13h30 alors que
vous avez menées là tous les tous les
vendredis il ya aussi des étudiants qui
vient ici un exactement il ya des
étudiants qui font aussi du gol dans le
cadre de leur formation et qui sont
valorisés à hauteur de 3 cts dans l'ain
dans le cadre de leurs études et ils
viennent le jeudi après midi
ça marche bien ils ont l'air de jouer
pas mal ils sont assez bordure oui alors
le golf a eu beaucoup de succès puis on
est tellement bien reçu à jardy que du
coup on a doublé le les groupes cette
année on a fait deux groupes et là vous
êtes en présence du groupe un peu avancé
qu' un bon niveau assez correct on va
vous laissez vous entraîner
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
alors va entamer notre séquence
technique avec nicolas qui est pro
bonjour ça va bien très bien alors il ya
alpha aussi gai qui est ici et vous
allez on va parler aujourd'hui de la
façon de placer sa balle dans l'instance
un pool swing exactement à ce que au
final si la balle est bien placé dans le
sens dès le début tout est bien mis en
place pour que la balle soit réussie
alors certes un petit défaut technique
et à pouvoir faire que la balle soit
raté mais en général si on est bien au
début d'être fortes chances qu'on soit
bien à la fin et c'est vrai que c'est un
détail comme ça ça semble être un détail
auquel on prête souvent pas attention
hein parce qu'on se dit c'est naturel ou
alors on se met là on se met devant là
bas ne regarde pas tellement et c'est
comme ça qu'on peut rater des coups bas
en général un golfeur se met devant la
balle affiche pas trop et boum itamar
fois la balle part à gauche parfois le
par à droite on this et la tête les
éléments les genoux alors au final
jusque là face les pas bien nautique
surtout le club n'est pas orienté pile
comme ils font entre les pieds alors on
va commencer alpha avec un fer 9
exactement donc faire assez ouvert donc
où est ce qu'on place la balle quand on
joue avec un fer 9 en général faut
partir toujours dû faire cette fait
recette au mieux des pieds d'accord en
vue que le fair 9 est un club qui est
légèrement plus ouvert que le fait
recette on a tendance se mettre un petit
peu plus à droite
oui d'accord un ou deux centimètres
c'est sur les préférences de chacun mais
plutôt partie droite
ok on regarde avec alpha 1 voilà le
placement la balle est un peu au centre
droit qui ont pesé si on peut dire ça
après l'essentiel c'est que la balle
partent quand il faut donc sur les
joueurs il ya toujours une petite
préférence
donc la balle l'école bien et l'avons
donné la balle est la balle monte oh non
c'est pas parce que on est à droite que
le club est fermé
exactement et plus en club est ouvert
plus on va se mettre à droite pour que
la malle d'école et surtout quand elle
atterrit elle ne roule pas beaucoup
c'est ça le but est ce que ça permet
d'avoir avec justement ces fins ouvert
un sourire un peu plus vertical d'avoir
la balle un peu à droite même pu en club
sera ouvert puis en général il va être
fermé plus on va se rapprocher de la
balle d'accord plus on est proche de la
balle plus le geste va être verticale et
inversement ou temps avec un driver ou
en ange est un peu plus horizontale
quand donc ça c'est avec un fer ouvert
alpha si vous voulez bien prendre un
peut-être emploie 3 maintenant on va
passer un an fin voilà quasiment mais
quand même en travers neuf et un bois 3
c'est un fer 9 ckoi l'ouverture à peu
près faire neuf font toujours de 42° 42
degrés là on est à 16 degrés voilà quoi
demi environ
là alors là c'est quoi on se passe
plutôt sur la sur le pied gauche c'est
l'intérêt de lui du bon pied gauche faut
pas oublier que le club les plus grands
donc naturellement il va se déplacer un
peu plus son arrière pour qu'ils aient
plus de places pour qui la meilleure
balle et halak a effectivement quoi on
peut le constater la balle est davantage
vers la gauche n'ont pas été repris et
deux roues un tel pied gauche pour dire
ce sera plutôt le driver d'accord un
centimètre près un peu plus ça reste à
gauche quoi qu'il arrive donc on a bien
vu faire neuf un peu sur l'a1 peu abba
centre droit ont dit c'est l'art du
million ses calanques la droite
évidemment bois 3 on va aller vers un
peu vers le bas vers la gauche
exactement et qu est ce qu on pourrait
essayer maintenant un sand belle leçon
dois-je ah oui ça c'est important parce
qu'à l'heure c'est l'extrême gauche
le son doit du vote extrême droite
d'accord tout simplement
donc là la balle est pratiquement sûr le
pire droit c'est exactement par un angle
d'attaqué très descendants pour mettre
un maximum de spin pour que la balle
d'école très haut et c'est pour la
théorie elle s'arrête le plus tôt
possible
très important et on constate que vu que
le club est quand même plus petits
automatiquement il s'est un peu plus
rapproché de la barre et bien sûr oui
tout à fait pascal que b voilà derniers
essais au sol wade lui a touché
on va via caballé la balle va s'arrêter
très vite du coup un an générale 2,3
mètres plus long mais de spin plus la
balle s'arrête ravis de voir même va
revenir en arrière alors nicolas on a
bien compris la position des clubs
depuis le fait recette au milieu et puis
après voici 5 etc
on va un peu plus à gauche les autres
plus tout à fait à droite mais si je
veux faire monter la balle très vite est
ce que par exemple cgt je peux mettre
mon sandwich sur le champ gauche pour
kamal bond plus vite sur le papier c'est
bien tenté mais fogeo lui une chose sûre
mais en sandwich qui est un club déjà
très ouvert et qu'on met davantage leur
pied gauche 11 de fringues tempête et
donc de rater la balle et inversement
avec un driver qui a comme très fermé si
on met beaucoup trop à droite
même principe catatrophe donc ce qu'il
faut en général c'est toujours respecté
leurs relations entre le club que l'on a
et comment de position de l'instance
après petite variante ans que ça paraît
qu'elle marche
là est l'essentiel voilà merci
infiniment des gras merci beaucoup et
enfin merci bien
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi et à très vite
pour reparler de golf sur tv 78
[Musique]